the Trump administration is taking its
toughest stance yet in cracking down on
illegal immigration on Friday the
Justice Department demanded proof from
nine so-called sanctuary cities that
they are complying with federal
immigration authorities the
jurisdictions include the state of
California and some of the nation's
biggest cities including New York Roxana
Saberi is at City Hall right here in New
York City where Mayor Bill DeBlasio is
pushing back against the white house
Roxana good morning good morning guys
the Justice Department sent letters to
the sanctuary cities saying if they
don't cooperate with authorities in
finding and deporting illegal immigrants
they could lose federal grant money but
it was a separate statement from the
Justice Department about immigration
enforcement that set up a dispute
between New York City and the Trump
administration and it just shows how out
of touch this administration is with
what's happening on the ground in this
city New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio
had harsh words for the Justice
Department and its leader Attorney
General Jeff Sessions he was reacting to
a Justice Department news release that
calls New York City soft on crime it is
now rageous statement and it's absurd on
its face and ignores a quarter century
of progress in this city and bringing
down crime the Justice Department's
actions are part of a stepped-up effort
to fulfill one of President Trump's
signature campaign promises a crackdown
on illegal immigration the letters sent
to places like New York Chicago and
Miami Friday threatened to strip
millions of dollars in federal law
enforcement funding from those cities if
they don't help federal authorities find
and deport illegal immigrants while
visiting a border security facility in
San Diego session said sanctuary cities
undercut the ability to fight crime they
help these gangs to refill their ranks
and puts innocent life including the
lives of countless law-abiding
immigrants in danger by refusing to
share vital information with federal law
enforcement during Friday's news
conference sessions addressed a separate
controversy that's followed him this
week he faced a backlash after making
remarks about a federal court judge in
Hawaii who blocked the
residents travel ban on six
muslim-majority countries
I really am amazed at a judge sitting on
an island in the Pacific can issue an
order that stops seeing the president
United States from what appears to be
clearly his statutory and constitutional
powers some took the comments as a
slight to the state of Hawaii but on
friday session said he was only
criticizing the judge's decision one
judge is overruled the constitutional
authority of the President of the United
States to protect America through his
executive order while the president's
travel ban remains on hold the the ninth
sanctuary jurisdictions have until June
30th to show that they are complying but
Anthony a number of city leaders say
they will remain defiant even at the
risk of losing federal funding Roxana
Saberi at New York City Hall thanks
Roxana